The Joe Rogan experience,
what race races that Lee's gonna
run and don't run those races. Yeah.
Run a different run a different race.
That's always been money you feel about
trans athletes, you know? Uh, it's a good,
it's a good question.
I think it's,
we're really going to go through
like a cultural change on how we
think about that, you know, and
it's, it's morphing so quickly,
you know what I mean? Um, uh,
I'm very much because I am of this opinion
that there is no such thing as like
perfect fairness.
And when we make those distinctions,
we're always choosing who to allow and
because I think we should choose to allow
like trans people to
participate in society.
I'm for and inclusive approach where,
you know,
we're able to like find a,
find like a model that allows those
folks to compete fairly in a way that
everybody's happy with. I think that's
the, I think that's what we should do,
you know? Um, and that to me is like,
that's what makes me like sports more,
you know? Um, is those
comparisons like um, you know,
another thing that pissed me off so much
was like, ah, fuck, what's his name?
The um, the disabled runner
who then killed his girlfriend.
Oh yeah.
The [inaudible] and people were
saying about this guy that his,
that is a, a prosthetic gave him
an advantage. Now, first of all,
there's no fucking way that's true
because he doesn't have muscles, muscles.
Conversely, food into does give you
an advantage. I mean to do things.
So I think mechanically it does cause
their springs. They essentially,
the way his leg works with those
things is you put, you've seen them,
right? They don't even look remotely like
feet. I've seen any other cheesy things.
Yeah. Yeah. It's a crazy like,
but dude, the SI's hooked but,
but hold on site, that's not an advantage
because how mechanics work, right?
Is that a spring you put energy in
and you get a little bit less energy out.
Right.
So cause that's the laws
of thermodynamics, right?
You can't get more out than you put in,
except a muscle does give you more than
you put in because a muscle converts
food into energy for a
brief period. Right. Um,
and so he does, he has sprint, he doesn't
have springs. Sorry. He has springs.
He doesn't have a machine in his leg.
The way the rest of us do that
creates force out of food.
The question is whether or not
the lower half of his legs,
which is what he's missing, could
make up for the, the advantage,
the mechanical advantage of
the shape of those things,
which applies all sorts of really
unusual leverage when you're right,
it's totally or not, I mean I
don't, I don't know if it's,
I mean I don't know if you took him
with full legs and took him with those
things if they'd run
the same amount of time.
But the thing that we can run
fast as fuck with those things.
You've seen those guys,
well he could write,
but where's all the other double
amputees who are like, you know,
common of track and field. How
many of them are trying to, I mean,
the Para Olympics is huge. There's like
a ton of Paralympic athletes, you know,
like I've been told that it
has an mechanical advantage
by someone who actually
should know what they're talking about.
But I want to,
I would like to look it
up to those, um, legs.
[inaudible] I remember reading stuff
the time from, you
know, uh, know exercise,
whatever, uh, athletic scientists forget
what it's called. Um, who said that?
Who said that it didn't, right? Yeah, but
so that's a debate that we could have.
Right. But the point that I was trying to
make was looking at that Olympics. God,
that's a better event with that guy in
it. You know, I'm so happy he was in it.
Right?
Like if it does give you an
advantage comes in second place,
you know? Well, so,
so the point is when we make
the rules of a game, right,
and this is the point of our episode
about Games, which is about the Olympics.
Actually when we make the
rules of the game we are,
there's no such thing as a perfectly fair
competition that would be designed by
God to be perfect and be
perfectly fair. Right, right.
We're always making choices about what
kind of competition we want to have and
who we want to allow into it and
what sort of outcome we want to have.
You know what I mean?
Just like in baseball,
too many home runs moved
them round up or down.
You know how they changed the rules a
little bit because they want more homeruns
same thing with same thing
with track and field.
We changed the rules a little bit to allow
this person and not allow this person.
Right. I think that when
we're talking about people,
we should always try to include more
people, not less. We should, you know,
like if and if hey,
if you're a double amputee and you can
get your way into the Olympics and you
can make a plausible case,
I think we should try to entertain that
notion and we should try to find a way
to get that guy in there. Right. As
far as trans athletes go, you know,
we could have,
we could sit here and talk for three
hours about like all the different ways
that hormones might affect your body.
It might not affect your body.
And I'm not an expert on that,
and I don't want to claim to be right.
But a sports with a
trans athletes who are,
uh, you know, competing with the, you
know, with their gender, right? That's,
uh, that is a sporting world that
I'm Morgan trusted in. Right?
And I think we should find
a way to make that happen.
I know it's gonna be really complicated,
complicated and messy, right? Um, and, uh,
there's gonna be a lot of debate about
it and it's gonna make it's going to be
uncomfortable. You know, there's gonna
be a lot of arguments, but, you know,
I hope that that's the world that
we've moved forward to. That's my,
that's my point of view.
My point of view is that there's a
reason there's a distinction. Uh,
there's a reason why we make the
distinction to have male athletics versus
female athletics. The reason is
that males have a physiological,
physiological advantage over women. So
in most sports, most physical sports,
we do not have males compete with females.
The question becomes when someone who
was male transitions and becomes female,
do those same physiological
advantages apply? And what,
what are the, what is the evidence? Well,
the evidence and competition seems to
be that it shows that it does apply,
particularly in weightlifting,
rugby, mountain biking, power,
heavy sports that are,
that favor larger people,
stronger bodies,
males that transitioned to females have
a significant advantage and they're
breaking world records.
So if you're a woman and you're a natural
woman and you don't take any extra
hormones or male hormones,
you not taking steroids or any sort
of performance enhancing drugs,
you're doing your very best to compete
and you're at the top of the heap.
But then someone comes
along that was a man for 30
years and decides that they're going
to be a woman and this has happened and
literally transition a few months ago
and compete as a woman and destroys
records and dominates you in that sport.
That's bullshit.
And that's not competing
on a level playing field.
That's a person who is biologically a
male and who was a male for 30 plus years
of having testosterone run through their
body and effect their tendon strength
and affect the shape of their bones and
the mechanical advantages of the male
hips versus the female hips.
And then they're competing with smaller
people who have been a woman their whole
life. It's not fair. It's,
it's is as much cheating as taking
steroids when the other person doesn't or
taking performance enhancing drugs
when the other person doesn't.
Maybe even more so maybe in
more so because you also have,
there's a bunch of advantages in terms
of reaction time that males enjoy.
It's like it's some significant difference
in reaction time between males and
even untrained males versus female
professional athletes. Well,
uh, I disagree and I have,
what do you disagree about?
I've, I've already, well the,
my main point being the one that
I already made, right? That like,
I don't think that there is such a thing
as a perfectly level playing field.
I think we decide what kind of
playing field we want to have. Sure.
The distinction where we
don't allow men to come
and women's divisions.
And I think that that distinction
may be breaking down a bit. Right?
And I think it may be time to
break down that distinction.
The male should be able to compete in
the women's division of weightlift.
Uh, no, I don't necessarily. Um,
but can, if they transition, uh,
well first of all, uh, uh, the,
there's, there's a lot of
stuff to break down, right?
And I'm not an expert on the subject,
right? So it's just sort of my,
off the top of my head.
Um, one thing is, you know,
you're postulating a particular
person who decided to transition, uh,
at the age of 30. Right? And they were
very big and strong before, right?
And they decide to transition. Now that is
a type of person that exists. Right? Um,
I think over the next certainly 30
years, we're going to see, you know,
now that people are starting to understand
that being trans is just a way that
people are, right. They're just
people who are trans. You know,
and this is something that we're
going to accept and support, right?
You're seeing folks tra transition
much, much earlier age, you know, um,
uh, and, and so if someone is, if someone
is transitioning from the age of like,
you know, seven years old, right? Um, and,
uh, you know, working with those hormones,
you know, from that age, right,
they're not going to have their bodies
situations can be very different than the
one that you, that you
postulated. Right. Uh,
I also know from my trans
friends that the, uh,
the effects that the hormones have on
your body are like really profound.
You know, like really, really
profound. Like we're not like, um, uh,
to a surprising degree. Right.
Uh, and so, uh, you know,
I have, look, if the question
is how does, you know,
how does a person who taking hormones
at a, at a particular age, right,
how does their body change and how's
that affect visa vi athletic performance?
I don't know. We're in such
new territory here, right?
Well,
we certainly are,
and we particularly would just scratched
upon the idea of kids transitioning in
a very early age.
I mean,
there's been more scientific evidence
that points that if kids don't do that,
then when they wanted to be trans at
an early age, they just become gay men.
And that there's nothing
wrong with that either. Um,
there's no reason to give kids hormones
and there's no reason to decide before a
person's frontal lobe is completely full,
completely fully developed,
which doesn't even take place till like
25 people don't know who they are. You,
yes, a seven year old you, you won't even,
people don't even give their seven year
old phones. You don't let them vote.
You're going to let them decide what
sex they're going to be for the rest of
their lives.
The research that I've seen, and
again, I'm not an expert on this and,
and you know, I'd love to, this is
a conversation. This is something I,
I'd love to talk about on our show
and I'd specifically love, you know,
this is before does the kind of topic
where I really want to make sure that I
know the research and that,
um, you know, also speaking
to Trans folks, you know, um,
in, in this conversation. But so to
touch on just what I've, you know,
my own experience and what I've,
the research I've seen,
the research I've seen is that
trans kids from a young age, uh,
they are incredibly consistent in their w,
you know,
when they're expressing their gender
identity, um, and, and that and that
human beings. Yeah, yeah.
But the, that's, that's fit.
I'm just narrative by saying they're
incredibly consistent. Billy,
if you polled these people, like what
are you talking about? Like a, you,
I mean that's, I, I look, I don't have
the research in front of me that I saw,
so I can't like go into the details on it.
But like, yeah, it was, I mean, it was,
you know,
it was a research that was surveying and
tracking like trans kids who declared
their identity from a young age. Did it
change? The answer was, uh, generally no,
it really didn't. Um, and, uh, you
know, I have a friend who has a,
who has a trans kid, um, don't know
the kids exact age, but you know,
we're in the age range that
we're talking about and you know,
he's explained that like, well, you know,
my child from a very young age
consistently like said, I am a girl, like,
and has never contradict themselves,
never changed their mind.
And so the humane thing and the thing
that he felt was going to do as a parent
was to like, embrace that choice
on his child's part. Right. Um,
and yeah,
that's,
we embrace that choice
meaning hormone really.
I shouldn't even phrase it as a choice,
like, like embrace that identity. Um,
but it is a choice, right?
I mean, if I choosing to add
hormones to a child's body,
that's a choice.
Uh, it's a multiple, the choice. It's,
it's the, it's the choice on the,
on the part of the parent. Um, it's not
a choice in the, on the, on the, uh,
on the part of the child to like,
in the same way that being said with
it being gay isn't a choice. Yeah.
That's who they are.
If they think that they're a girl,
why do you have to give them
hormones to make them more of a girl?
Uh, because uh, I'm sorry, can
you expand on the question?
Simple.
If you say
that the child thinks it's a girl,
so you're going to give the child hormones
[inaudible] if the child thinks it's
a girl, let it be a girl. Like you
don't have, why are you adding hormones?
If you're shooting hormones into the
child and you're affecting the child's
development, you're saying that's not
a choice. That's nonsense. Of course.
It's a choice. You're choosing to
chemically change this child's body.
He choosing to inject things into this
child's body on a regular basis that are
going to radically affect the physical
development of their body. Yeah.
And you're saying that
this isn't a choice.
What's definitely a choice to do that.
So,
so what Trans People Express,
um, and again, I'm not an expert.
This is from me talking to my trans
friends and, and you know, uh,
seeing what other trans folks say.
Um,
is that the experience of being
trans and not receiving hormones,
right? And not, uh, having the
body that you identify with,
the feeling of Dysphoria, right,
is, um, extremely like painful,
um, and is a condition unto itself,
right? Um, and, uh, the, the,
the feeling of not belonging with the body
that you have of that mismatch, right?
That seems to be in the
broad variety of humanity,
the way that some people are born,
right? Where their inner self, right.
The self that they are,
they're like, I am a, you know,
they're not thinking they are a woman.
They're like,
this is the person that I am doesn't
match the body that they have. Right.
And that gives them extreme distress.
Right? And that leads to, you know,
suicide that leads to, uh, you know,
uh, other damaging behaviors. Right.
And the best treatment for that,
that we know exists is
to, uh, you know, have,
do gender confirmation
via a hormones. Um, and
that doesn't effect the suicide rate.
The suicide rate for
Trans People's very high,
postop and preop really doesn't get
affected by whether or not you treat them
well. The operation, you know, one of
the questions conception is why is that?
Is that because they're not accepted
by society and we're not more loving?
Could it be underlying issues that are,
that are causing them to feel
this way in the first place?
Like what is it we don't know? And I felt,
I'm sure it varies widely. Look, so I,
all I can do
is a defer to the experts that,
that I know about this, right.
So, um, uh, you know, for instance,
there's an author named Brynn
Tannehill who is a former, uh,
uh,
former military helicopter pilot.
I just interviewed her for my new
podcast that's coming out soon,
called a factually,
I'm doing it on Earwolf and it's like
a long form interview podcast. Um,
and so she's one of the people who's
affected by, uh, the, uh, Trump, uh,
uh, military ban on Trans
Service people, you know,
so that's why you brought her around
because she's trans. Yeah. Um, and uh,
she wrote a fantastic book
called everything you need
to know about trans that
like she's a, she is now
a researcher, right. Um,
and she went into really
deep detail about like,
here is all of the medical science here
is all of here's all the science about
it. And so at this point in the
conversation, I would say, hey man,
I just got to bone up on,
you know, on that part.
Cause I don't want to speak
to suicide rates. My entire
or concern is with children.
My concern is not with young adults
deciding to take steps to confirm their
gender identity,
who they feel they really are.
I'm all for you doing whatever you
want to do when you're an adult,
when your mind is formed.
But people change their mind.
They change their opinion,
they changed their thoughts.
There's nothing wrong with
just deciding to be a gay man.
your body, uh, you know,
as you grow and mature and develop,
you growing out of these ideas,
some wheel in some world
and the ones who won't,
they always have the option to
do something later on in life.
But if you do something to hormonally
block a child very, very early on,
there's no turning back from that.
Well let me say, let me say a
few things of that. First of all,
it's not wrong to be
concerned about children.
And there's a reason this is the most
intense part of this conversation and I
think it's correct, right? Because we're
all very concerned about children. Right?
But I do want to say, first
of all, I don't think it's
correct that trans people,
if they don't receive hormones from an,
from a young age,
they simply become gay men.
Because I know it happens very often.
I Know Trans People,
cause it was a big article
that was written about that
recently where they were
talking about whether or not
gender confirmation surgery
and hormone blockers on
young children is ethical
because of this fact.
And this was what they were talking about,
where people at one point in time wanted
to be trans and they listed several
famous examples and then as they
became older, just decided to be gay,
including women who wanted to be men
who just became gay women. And I think,
what's that girl's name that was in John
Wick? Ruby rose. She was one of those,
she wants to be trans when she was
younger and now she's just a gay woman.
So look, I, I know, I know
quite a few, uh, trans folks.
Right? Um, and I have to be honest,
none of the ones that I know where,
I don't know any trans women personally
who are gay men up until they
transitioned. Right. Um, I
know quite a few trans women
who are straight men. Right.
Um, or who, you know, lived their lives
as to presented as straight men. Right.
And then transitioned. Right. Um,
as an order come lesbians. Uh,
yeah, I mean that's, that's one
of the ways that people can be,
I really recommend that. Um, oh,
the other thing I was going to say is
that I do know also among the Trans folks
that I know where the Trans
people who speak about this,
that I've heard so many of them say,
I wish I had access.
I knew this about myself at a very
young age and I wish to God that I had,
that we had, I had had the ability to
receive these hormones at a young age.
My life would be so much better.
And I'm not gonna Argue with those folks.
You know
these folks either.
But you have to address the fact that
there are people that have gone through
transition surgery and said,
I wish to God that I never did this.
There's a lot of those people too.
So if you're looking for anecdotal
evidence and you want to be objective,
you kind of have,
I'm sure we can. I'm sure we
can find the anecdotes. Um,
I'm very curious and this is what
I'd go consult my friend, uh,
or my recent interview subject Tana Hills,
uh, work on this to see how many, uh,
see how many are in each
group right now, which, which,
which sets of these
folks are the outliers.
I think the folks that you're talking
about are probably the outliers,
but I can't, you know,
uh, confirm that all sir
juries have potential costs.
However,
according to a Swedish study
of 324 patients, three 40,
1% of whom were born female surgery was
associated with considerably higher risk
for mortality,
suicidal behavior and psychiatric
morbidity than the general population.
So that's people who got the surgery.
I am curious, wait, 3.4, 1% of them.
The devil of this is in the details,
right? Because how much is the,
is the higher risk? What does it mean?
3.1% of those who were born female
from were born female and the
other ones were born male.
The males that transition to
females is what it's saying.
It's only saying a small percentage of
them were born female that transitioned
to male, but the larger percentage
was males who transitioned to female.
And that the surgery that they received
was associated with considerably higher
risks for mortality,
suicidal behavior and psychiatric
morbidity than the general population.
Sure.
That's not healing them.
That's saying that having that surgery
is associated with higher risks of
mortality, suicidal behavior
and psychiatric morbidity.
But it also says above following surgery,
patients report lower gender dysphoria
and improved sexual relationships right
before they killed themselves.
Everything's awesome. Well,
this isn't saying that people
are killing themselves. You know,
you're looking for,
you're looking for something that confirms
a previously established opinion and
as are you, you know, I mean we're, we're,
we're looking at this and just
look at the, we should be,
we should always be careful of drawing
too much from, you know, a single study.
I'm like, look at it widely.
Right. Um, but, uh, uh,
what was the point I was about to
make? Um, it flipped my head. Uh, I,
I'm sort of at the, Oh, here's
what it was. Um, surgery.
Another thing I know from,
from speaking with Trans
folks is that surgery is
overemphasized, right? And then,
and that, uh, surgery for those
folks is not the, you know,
we as sort of straight says people tend
to put too much emphasis on like, oh,
did you get the surgery
yet? Or not? You know,
and really it's more about what are
you living as and what is, you know,
what sort of set of hormones do you have?
Right. Um, but I, I would really, uh,
one of the, I've sort of reached the
limit of like my facility with this topic.
I really want to shout out, um, uh,
videos made by a friend of mine.
Her videos are called a contra points.
Her name's Natalie when,
and she does these increase.
She's a former, a philosopher,
former philosophy phd,
and she does these incredibly funny videos
about, is not just about transitions,
about all types of things. Um, uh, she had
really great one about comedy recently.
Um, but she really breaks down like a lot
of these, a lot of misconceptions, right.
And has really changed every time I watch.
One of her videos,
I'm like learning new things and like new
ideas are like pop, pop, pop in my head,
you know. Um, and I,
I think you should check them out and
you might enjoy talking to her on the,
on the show. She's like a really
fascinating person. Contra points.
It's an incredibly complex subject.
You really had a really is
angel on the podcast before who
transitioned from female to male,
which is also a different and
interesting thing. Yeah. Um, you know,
and he said that his whole life just
felt like he was a boy and he didn't
understand why he didn't have a penis.
He didn't understand like the whole,
it didn't make sense. And then once
he transitioned to being a male,
then he felt complete. You
know, I don't deny that.
My entire concern is that you're making
decisions for children and that this is
a completely new thing with
no historical precedent.
We've never done this before.
There's not like a history of hundreds
of years of hormone blocker blockers
being used on young children and whether
or not that is healthy and promotes a
positive life. I feel like if
a child thinks there are girl,
let them live as a girl,
but you don't have to hormonally
engage with their body with chemicals.
It just seems crazy. It
seems ill advised. It does.
It seems like this movement of acceptance
and progressive thinking in in in many
ways is a fantastic thing.
It's a fantastic movement.
But this seems to me to be,
uh,
a leap and that you're making this leap
to confirm your ideology and to confirm
that, you know, you're 100% cool with
trans people and you're 100% co and you,
you're going to recognize this child is
trans, but you're doing something. You're,
you're doing something to this child's
body that you can't turn around.
And if this child decides at whatever
age we decide that you can make rational
decisions to transition as trans,
let them fully develop first.
Let them be a person.
Let them make these decisions.
If you want to identify as a woman,
you and you want to keep your penis,
that should be fine too.
There's nothing wrong with that.
If you want to keep a functional penis,
you want to identify as a woman and not
even take hormones. Who Cares? Do that,
do that.
But when you're stepping in
to a developing baby that's
only been alive for six
years and you're shooting chemicals into
its body to change the way it develops.
Show me the research.
Show me the decades of peer
reviewed studies on one of
the most important things
that we know of the development
of a human being. Well,
you're going to hear more
hormonally interact with
their body and some sort of a
random doctor Frankenstein sort of way,
like say, how much evidence do we know?
What evidence do we have
that this is a a powerful,
absolute like intelligent,
smart way to handle a child's
life over the long term.
Like when these kids grow to be 60 as
opposed to kids who don't get the the
hormone shots when they're six, they,
these people are 15% more happy.
There's nothing like that,
but yet people are jumping into it because
it seems like the thing to do because
it seems like the tide of society
is moving in that direction.
Well, I, I don't jump into
it for that reason. Um,
I do think that when we're talking about
an issue that affects those people,
right? The first thing we should do
is listen to those people, right?
So the children listen to the children
and listen to the adults, right?
Who said used to be that child.
Okay. You know, but they are not that
child. And you know, to you said the look,
everyone's different. So for them to
say, I was that child, that's nonsense.
You were a similar child in a similar
situation. You are not that shadow.
They're not literally, but they
don't know how that child is feeling.
They don't know how much that child is
being influenced by its environment.
They don't know how much their thoughts
and their expressions are being
encouraged by their parents.
They don't know that child. Sure.
So my point is,
when we're taught,
when you and I are talking
about this right now,
we're speaking pretty
hypothetically, right? We're,
we're talking about a child that is
not in the room that we don't have.
We're talking about a fictional trial,
right?
So what we really care about are
the actual people, right? Um,
and when we talk to the actual
trans folks, right. And,
uh, talk to, you know, say, Hey, what
do you think, you know, how do you feel?
And, uh, you know, include
them in that conversation.
I think we have a different
conversation about it. You know,
we do have an open conversation,
but we also have a different conversation.
We talked to people that have regret from
transition surgery cause there's a lot
of those. Sure. But we're not, we don't
have either of those folks in the room.
Right. You know, we have to
acknowledge that they're real
as well. Yeah. I, I don't,
uh, I'm not, I'm not dismissing
that those people are real. Right.
But when we say if you
talk to Trans folks,
you get this impression that's
not necessarily true. Um, uh,
Wa a wide range of impressions.
I wasn't just,
I wasn't talking about specifically
the impression that I wasn't saying we
should reason from anecdotal evidence.
Right. I'm saying that, um, look,
the last conversation I had
with a person about this was a,
uh,
was a trans military veteran who is
a researcher who wrote a book on,
uh, on these issues. Right.
Comprehensively looked at the research
and told me that the research shows, uh,
that the evidence that you're asking for,
um,
exists maybe not on a 30 year timeline,
but there have been studies of this and
here's what we know about them, right.
About Children's. Um, uh,
yeah, I mean that's a,
that is my understanding of the role.
I have not looked at the research
myself and you know, I don't have,
not on this topic on my
shows, the positive benefits
of children transitioning.
I don't think that exists.
Well,
we can't solve that in this conversation
right here. Um, but, uh, so my point is,
look, I'm not going to go out on a
limb and tell you more than I can.
I can say off the top of my head, right,
because I'm not an expert on the subject.
Uh, this is something
that, you know, if I,
if this were something we had done on
our show and I had doubt dive into the
research more, I can tell
you more. I know it exists,
but I can tell you what I have been told
exists by people who have made it their
business to know, you know.
Um, so, uh, so, you know,
that would be my next step in the
conversation. Um, uh, but, you know,
that's what I'm saying is,
uh, those are, you know,
including those folks in this conversation
is a really critical part of it for
me. Um, so yeah. Uh,
well it's a conversation in the
world needs to have for sure. Yeah.
And I think it's one that we
will have and you know, again,
just to bring it back to athletics,
right? Um, I think that the,
uh, undeniable existence
of trans, you know,
children to teenagers to adults,
right, who want to compete, right. Um,
and who make a compelling case to is that,
that they should be able to compete,
right. Um, is going to be something that
we're going to have to grapple with.
You know, I think there's going to be easy
answers to it. Um, and now, yeah, I mean,
I think the real,
the legitimate solution as a Trans
League or a trans division to have a male
division of female division of Trans
Division if you want to compete
athletically. That's fair to me. That
makes sense. Well, I hope that there's,
you know, like say with the, you've
got the Para Olympics, right?
And the Paralympics is really like, it's
divided. Why do you know how they do it?
Where they do like all
the different levels for,
you've got this much amputated or you're
this mobile and you can compete in this
way. You know? And so that's really
great to make a way that, you know,
those folks can compete on a level as a
playing field as we can be, get, you know,
given the manifold variations in human
bodies. Right. But the fact that I,
Oscar Pistorius,
which by the way we should bring up again,
he killed his girlfriend,
which is a very weird part of the story.
And he said he thought she was a
robber bazaar. Completely bizarre.
But the fact that he was able to
compete in the Olympics, right,
not just in the Paralympics. I think
such a wonderful thing, you know.
And so I would hope that whatever
organization we come up with, you know,
allows for the,
uh,
allows for humans and all their variations
to compete in the Maine League as
well. Right. Honestly,
because as possible,
they come up with bionic legs like
Steve Austin from the $6 million man.
There's some people out there,
they'll cut their fucking legs
off to run faster and that's real.
There are people that want to win so bad
they would cut the bottom of their legs
off to get bionic prosthesis.
They wouldn't really for sure 100%
would, would you? No, I wouldn't,
but I'm not crazy. Look this
people, I mean these are
hands just cause they, they,
they're,
they are a bit,
do you know that people have that feeling
that they're supposed to be disabled?
So they amputated? Yes. Their hands. Yes.
There's people with all sorts
of psychological disorders,
but the need to win is so
insanely strong in some people.
And if they found out that,
hey man,
well who gives a fuck about
your feet and your calves? Man,
they're going to look
just like feet and calves,
except they allow you
to run 45 miles an hour.
But I don't think people would do it.
Isn't that a little similar
to the argument when people
say, Oh, trans bathrooms,
it's just so man are just
going to lie about it.
So they can go in the bathroom and peep
at women and then when you actually
expand that, right, and
you're like, hold on a second,
you're telling me a dude is going to tell
the entire world I am. I'm not a man.
I'm a woman. They're going to
start dressing differently.
They're going to take hormones. They're
going to like live with the stigma, right?
They're going to one of the
most stigmatized type of people.
You can be in America today as a trans
person and they're going to live with
that stigma.
They're gonna change our whole lives
and they're gonna do all of that just so
they can peep at women in the bathroom.
It doesn't make any sense.
Highly Unlikely, and it doesn't
make any sense, but it also,
that's not entirely what could happen.
What also could happen is you could get
some creep who dresses up like a woman
and goes to the mail to the women's
bathroom. You can get that. I mean,
I'm all for trans. You can't
have it now. I'm all for it.
But if you have a bathroom that allows
trans people and you get some creep who
says, I'm just gonna pretend to be
trans. If you don't think that's real,
then you're crazy. Of course
people do that. Of course there's,
and people have been arrested.
No, no, no. There is.
There's people who have been arrested,
men who were sex offenders who dressed
up as women and went into the women's
room and harassed women. There's
already been risks. This is,
but it's not because at least they have
trans transplant. But here's the thing,
they're not the trans people.
The people that are taking advantage of
a loophole and their creeps and they,
they probably wanted to go into
the female bathroom anyway,
but they just couldn't do it before.
And now that there's trans exclusive,
inclusive bathrooms,
some creeps have been arrested doing that.
They're not trans people.
The real problem is the creeps.
The real problem is not the Trans
people using the women's room.
They should of course be
able to use the women's room,
but the creeps can go like you
don't need a law for like it.
So if they're not trans people,
right,
they are not supposed to be in the
bathroom right there for way trans people.
And this is what people
were worried about,
but so have arrested people doing that.
So they could also do that.
Even if it was not a gender inclusive.
Sure.
It would be breaking the rules of the
bathroom and exactly the same way,
but everybody waking the bathroom man
in a dress versus them being trans.
See if you see a trans person, oftentimes
tramps, people look very masculine.
There's no need. If you're just
going to pretend to be trans,
there's no need to hide
what we have to ask address.
All you have to ask ourselves is if
the hypothetical or if the extremely,
extremely rare situation
that you're discussing,
right is so horrifying to us and such a,
uh,
such a big problem that
it's worth disenfranchising
millions of people from the
ability to simply go to the bathroom
when they need to. You know, if,
if that extreme edge case
or hypothetical case, right,
are we really going to, uh, are
we really going to, you know, uh,
hurt all, all of these actual people
who actually exist in say, hey,
I just need to Goddamn go to the
bathroom, you know, um, in a,
in a place that is, uh, you
know, safe for me. Right. Um,
and I don't think, I don't
think it is, you know, like we,
we can talk about that one edge
case all day long. Don't know.
But these are the days has
been more than one case.
But I think here's the
question, what were, what,
what are there more of,
are there more trans people or
they're more sexual predators?
100% more trans people than
sexual predators who are
specifically going to put
on a dress and in order to go
into a bathroom specifically,
yeah, I 100%. There's more trans people,
like, like by a factor of a million.
Why don't but affected million? I mean,
how many people are trans? Uh, what's the,
what's the numbers on that?
You know, I don't know. But
I would, I would consult my,
a consultant,
my friend Brian's book to find out,
because I'm sure it's
in there because she,
she wrote a book that breaks down all
these statistics called everything you
need to know about train
mind of a subject. You
know, as soon as you start bringing this
shit up, people go crazy because it's, uh,
it's complicated and people, they dig
their heels in the ground on both sides,
you know, and, you know, I tried
to have, um, you know, happy,
we able to have a conversation about,
I try to have a conversation
that's based on, you know, what,
I try not to say more than I than I
think I can say, uh, with, you know,
with surety. Um, and uh, you know,
but my basic principle is,
man,
I just want to defer to the humanity
of the people that I'm talking about.
You know what I mean? And rather than
saying, oh, well, here's my idea,
here's my concern. What about the
what, what if, uh, what if, uh,
a space alien were to come down and do
x, Y, z. You know what I mean? Rather,
rather than try to come up with thought
experiments about it, you know, it's like,
hey, there's some people in America,
they're making a polite request.
Can we use the bathroom? Please go
ahead. You know, that's, that's my,
that's what I default to write.
Just killed the perverts.
And if they kill the perverts
and you don't have any issues,
I think there's a way with sports
again, right? I genuinely think, hey my,
my default is I understand his problem.
I understand you're going to have female
athletes who, who are, who say, Hey,
wait a second. Is this fair? Right.
I think we can go forward with
good faith and find a way.
Let's find a model that works
for everybody. You know,
I think we can do it in
a way that respects the
humanity of the trans athletes
and assist athletes. I think that
we can do that. Um, and that's that,
that that will always be my thing.
It's easy to say, as an outsider,
if you're a female athletes,
it's been forced to compete with trans
women who used to be men for most of
their lives.
I think you'd have a different opinion
because I think they have a distinct
physiological advantage that's been
expressed many times. I mean it's,
there's just a lot of records have
been broken by Trans women who are now
weightlifters. And there's that
one who's the fucking dirt biker,
who's was a professional
dirt bike professional writer
before as a man and then
transitioned over to a woman. It's just
dominating these things. It's just,
I don't necessarily think it's fair.
I think just like,
it's not fair for a man
to compete as a woman.
I don't think that all those disadvantages
or those advantages rather go away
when you transition,
especially in a short time period.
I just don't think they do.
And I don't think there's any
evidence that shows they do.
There's a diminishing amount,
but how much so, and in fact,
there's a doctor, board
certified endocrinologist,
doctor Ramona crushed sick,
I think is her name. We did a whole
article on this about fighters,
about male fighters,
uh,
transitioning to becoming female and
competing as female, which has happened.
And they're saying that not only
does the estrogen therapy, uh,
it actually preserves bone density done,
doesn't just turn them into a woman
or turn them into female or the,
so their hormone profiles similar to
females but also preserves their masculine
bone density.
Because one of the reasons why women
lose bone density as they get older,
there's a lack of estrogen.
That's part of the reason why
osteoporosis kicks in well that they,
that stops it in its tracks when
you're, you're injecting, um,
female hormones into a male's frame.
So they maintain this male bone density.
Now there's also arguments that African
American female bone density is on,
in many cases, similar to a
white European male bone density.
So that's the,
um,
the argument about the outliers and
about whether or not it's a level playing
field because it most certainly is.
Yeah. I mean, so that, that's where
I get back to the idea that look,
could someone show that a athlete who,
a Trans Athlete who wants to compete is
going to have a physiological advantage
because of their history of transition.
Right. Could that be the case?
Sometimes. Probably so. You know, I'm not
gonna, I'm not gonna argue that. Let let,
well let's,
how about this,
cause I actually don't want to know
one way or the other because I have not
looked at any research on that, so
I don't want to make any claim. Um,
so let's just, let's just grant that
for the sake of this thought experiment.
Right. Okay. Um, so that being said,
let's compare that against every
single other advantage that every other
competitor could have. Socioeconomic
advantage, right? Country of origin. Um,
you know, whether or not they live in
Denver or if they live below sea level,
you know, like all those
different things. Right. Um, do,
is it humane to draw a line around that
one on earned advantage, right. Uh,
against all those other honor advantages,
you know,
is at what point does our fantasy of
having a level of having a true level
playing field end up hurting people, you
know, end up, end up excluding people.
And that's the conversation that I,
that I think we could have.